Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt es wieder was herzhaftes, wir machen Kabsa!
Das ist ein extrem leckeres Reisgericht, sehr sehr orientalisch gewürzt
und obendrauf geben wir sehr würzige Hähnchenschenkel.
Also für mich auch so ein bisschen Festessen-Charakter!
Also immer wenn wir z.B. mit Hamzas Familie sind und dort ganz viele Personen von essen,
dann macht meine Schwiegermama einen ganz großen Teller, also ungefähr die dreifache Menge
die ich jetzt heute mache! Und dann essen einfach alle aus diesem großen Teller,
also jeder schöpft sich so ein bisschen was ab
und ich freue mich immer wenn es das gibt!
So und jetzt zeige ich euch wie das funktioniert.
Wir starten jetzt hier in der Pfanne, da gebe ich jetzt Butter rein.
Ihr wisst ja Butter darf man nicht so hoch erhitzen, deswegen nehmt gern die mittlere Stufe.
Da gebe ich auch noch ein bisschen Butter Ghee dazu, einfach weil ich den Geschmack mag.
Gebe ich jetzt auch noch mit rein.
Dann lasse ich das schmelzen und dann geben wir Zimtstangen und 5 Kardamomkapseln mit dazu.
So, nach etwa einer Minute gebt ihr dann Ingwer dazu - den habe ich schön fein gehackt - und Knoblauch.
Einfach reinpressen und das dann auch eine Minute lang andünsten.
Wichtig ist halt wirklich die mittlere Stufe weil es ist ja kein hoch erhitzbares Öl sondern Butter.
Und da gebe ich jetzt Zwiebeln mit dazu, die habe ich auch grob gehackt.
Einfach mit andünsten so ungefähr 2min.
Und dann kommen weitere Gewürze mit dazu, ihr braucht generell sehr viele Gewürze hier.
Einige davon gibt es auch in meinem Shop.
Ich hab aber auch eine Gewürzmischung muss ich ehrlich sagen,
extra eine Gewürzmischung für Kabsa. Aber ich habe gedacht ich zeig euch den originalen Weg.
So und jetzt kommen die Gewürze dazu, die das Ganze schön köstlich machen:
Kreuzkümmel, Nelken, Koriander, Garam Masala, etwas Chili, Salz und Pfeffer.
Und jetzt gebe ich Tomaten dazu und lösche das Ganze so ein bisschen ab.
Ich hab jetzt Tomaten aus der Dose, die werden ja erntefrisch konserviert.
Ihr könnt aber auch frische Tomaten nehmen und einfach reiben.
Die hier sind ohne Haut also achtet darauf, dass ihr wenn ihr frische Tomaten nehmt,
auch die Haut einfach weglasst.
So, einfach mit dazu geben und dann so ungefähr 5min lang köcheln lassen.
So und jetzt geben wir Hähnchenschenkel dazu -
ihr könntet z.B. auch Hähnchenkeule nehmen - und braten das von beiden Seiten ca. 3-5min an.
So und im Anschluss geben wir Wasser dazu weil jetzt muss das Fleisch im Wasser garen.
Also Wasser so viel dazu geben, bis es gerade so das Fleisch bedeckt.
Dann einmal aufkochen lassen und dann mit geschlossenem Deckel ca. ich denk mal 25min lang
köcheln lassen. Das kommt natürlich immer darauf an, wie viel Fleisch ihr habt,
ob es dick ist oder - ich hatte gerade einen kurzen Aussetzer! - ob es
ja, relativ dick ist oder ein bisschen flacher. Und dann müsst ihr einfach schauen, dass es gerade so durch ist.
Jetzt nehme ich einmal das Hähnchen raus und geb das gleich auch nochmal in den Backofen
damit's von oben und unten richtig schön kross gegrillt werden kann.
So! Und da in dem Restsud wird gleich Reis gekocht, Reis habe ich auch schon abgewaschen.
Ihr wisst ja Reis enthält viel Stärke, daher immer abwaschen damit er eben nicht klebt.
Und dann zeige ich euch gleich nochmal eine sehr interessante Zutat!
So und jetzt sollte der Reis komplett bedeckt sein.
Ihr könntet noch ein bisschen Wasser nachgießen,
ihr könnt's aber auch im Nachhinein erst machen wenn ihr merkt, dass er nicht ganz gar ist.
Bei mir hat's jetzt genau perfekt gereicht.
Ich lass den gleich garen und dann wird er  richtig schön fein und jetzt kommt die interessante Zutat.
Und zwar habe ich hier getrocknete Limetten. Es gibt auch getrocknete Zitronen,
die sind dann komplett schwarz und die schmecken auch sauer.
Und die gibt man einfach so rein. Weil ich weiß, dass ihr die schwer bekommt,
lass ich's jetzt und zeige euch die Alternative. Das wird aber in der arabischen Küche total gerne verwendet!
So und die Alternative -
(H: Die sind auch extrem hart!)
Ja, dies sind mega hart! Die sind halt getrocknet, ne? Also ich fand's mega interessant!
Und ich habe jetzt hier alternativ einfach Zitronenscheiben ,
die müsst ihr jetzt für den typischen Geschmack jetzt einfach noch mit dazu geben.
Ich hatte das gerade einmal kurz aufkochen lassen.
Was auch noch mit dazu kommt ganz typisch sind Möhren, die müsst ihr ganz einfach fein raspeln.
Gebe ich jetzt auch noch mit dazu und dann lass ich das auf niedriger Stufe, also ich nehme jetzt Stufe 2 von 9,
dann lasse ich das garen mit geschlossenem Deckel. Denke mal das braucht so ungefähr 25min.
Und die ganz genauen Mengenangaben, die schreibe ich euch wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung auf.
So, die letzten Schritte vor dem Servieren sind folgende: das Fleisch einmal bei 190° C Ober- und Unterhitze
für 15 -20 min nochmal in den Ofen geben. Es kommt wie gesagt auf die Dicke des Fleisches an.
Wir wollen, dass die Haut nochmal schön kross wird und dann werde ich nur noch
Cashewkerne anbraten in Butter. Ihr könnt auch Mandeln nehmen oder Pinienkerne, auch sehr lecker.
Aber Nüsse in Kombination mit Reis: so lecker!
Und was auch noch typisch ist sind Rosinen, auch einfach in Butter anbraten.
Denkt dran: mittlere Stufe, Butter darf nicht so sehr erhitzt werden. Und dann servieren wir alles gemeinsam
in einer großen Schüssel und dann kann jeder davon essen.
Mega, mega lecker und sehr toll gewürzt! Probiert es unbedingt aus und schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare
ob ihr das Gericht schon kanntet oder ob es neu für euch ist. Ich hoffe dass -
wir fasten ja gerade und nach dem Fastenbrechen wird Hamza ja probieren
und ich hoffe Hamza, dass ich es wie deine Mama geschafft habe.
(H: Ich hoffe das auch für dich!)
Das sind hohe Ansprüche weil sie macht das einfach perfekt!
Aber ich hoffe, dass ich den Ansprüchen so ein bisschen gerecht werde.
Wir schauen mal! Ich denke mal da folgt wiedermal eine Instagram Story!
Ja, so machen wir's. Also euch einen wunderschönen Tag,
hinterlässt gerne ein Abo wenn ihr es nicht schon längst getan habt.
Und dann sehen wir uns auch bei meinem nächsten leckeren Rezept.
Tschüss!